[Music]
in shouldn't tweet bad news oh snap Oh
submitted by I breathe JK oh thank you
oh my god Brazil's president tweeted out
inappropriate materials to show his
disdain for the country's popular
festival whoo
what's the is it that's part it's like
Mardi Gras fur collars maybe he doesn't
like that cuz I love saying that Russian
I love that Mardi Gras is part of
culture in New Orleans it's so funny to
me because it's like when you're there
I've been there
Oh cuz it's so did such a [ __ ]
disgusting party yeah but it's like this
is our culture flash titties get drunk
and throw the necklaces right yes
everything's sticky everything sticky
even when it's not Mardi Gras because I
went there for Christmas everything
sticky sticky it shouldn't be this
sticky everybody they need to invest in
street-sweeping and dude and things that
are that are supposed to be sticky
aren't sticky that's how [ __ ] weird
New Orleans is do what supposed to be
sticky just like you're white [ __ ]
like a bar be able to attack paper or
whatever is not sticky there everything
around it is sticky
yeah they tape just like falls just
falls just fall right so this president
the Brazilian president he is it got to
he yes he uh Jer I think it's how you
pronounce his name for J a IR this is
what he looks like
okay he looks like he doesn't like cuz
you know ass is like a Brazilian like
staple he kind of looks to me like
spongebob when he doesn't have water to
our roasted people man roaster she's
been around the block every time you
guys I feel like a little kid being like
what held by my hand like oh good job
roasting
you're don't placate me damn thank you
it doesn't matter it's okay it was so
disappointed it is I know it's all good
yeah let's blame him it was a loud laugh
MA admittedly so this president tweeted
this out but it was in Brazilian this is
the translated to Portuguese I mean
sorry
thank you what do you so it says I do
not feel comfortable in showing but we
have to expose the truth of the
population to have knowledge and always
take their priorities this is what has
turned many blocks of streets in the
Brazilian Carnaval comment and take away
your conclusions and so it's this video
that they're calling a pornographic
video they're [ __ ] they're not
[ __ ] Oh are they sucking no I can
show you the video I would like to see
it okay so this video just in case we
can't show the video so this video it
shows two guys or three guys dancing on
top of this bus stop and then one of the
guys he ends up like diddling as a whole
and then the other building is a whole
like sticking his finger in his ass yes
I don't think that's Carnivale no that's
not car that's the dance of my people
climbing you know I was just scratching
yeah and then just scratching he's
presenting his ass part but that's not
even the thing though that's like a tiny
little thing the next thing that happens
is was like what the [ __ ] so the other
guy sticks out his dick and starts
peeing on the guy that was doing his
[ __ ] you know the guy that was doing
his [ __ ] is literally showering in it
okay yeah I don't think that's Carnivale
though whatever sure whenever I think
kind of all I think like the dancing the
music feathers and yeah that's what a
lot of people are saying like this is a
one like Idol Oh interesting
we're just taking advantage of the of
the atmosphere whoa whoa whoa they're
not being discussed and they're doing a
beautiful cultural dance all right let
me show you
the video what is he wearing nothing cuz
he's diddly in his butthole yeah it's
like open is that wait is he naked I
don't understand oh [ __ ]
that is no that's okay he's wearing a
Asmus uh your chap kind of felt his he
felt the spirit oh what the [ __ ]
oh wait he's peeing on him
oh he's washing his there it is Pete
well that guy's so calm
ptoo
I throw my shoe at them stop
so what what's the president my what's
the president of Brazil God against
drunk people in my mind
Wow looks like a [ __ ] orgy punk show
man yeah I thought there was drums and
dance and like a parade yeah with the
ladies with the big feathers and yeah
topless ladies they're not topless yeah
they are yeah there's a faux there's a
photo of Carnival at the Brazilian
barbecue place we go to and she's a
there's a topless lady in costume is it
in black and white yeah
so then after the president's we do this
out he started reading mentions I guess
and so he ended up asking what's the
golden shower oh my heart where are his
people [ __ ] people how do you let
your president look so foolish why no
one's gonna respect this guy named
presidents are too close to their
Twitter these days I feel like why
agreed I don't understand what was wrong
without about that tweet cuz he didn't
know what a golden shower was well he
shouldn't even be spending he's the
[ __ ] president why does he even need
to know what a golden showers you should
be worrying about like a president can't
ask a question yeah but not to the
[ __ ] open forum why not that's kind of
dope no it's not yeah I think it makes
him a real person I feel the Keith I
don't want him to be a real person I
want to be a [ __ ] president who's
like I ain't Ron it's up oh my god you
would've liked to colonial times be like
I [ __ ] we all look up to our leader no
boring country I want to make sure that
he's doing Ron country share your
thoughts
buddy read you know I don't want a king
I don't want a person on my oh that's my
role-model example person on carnival
carnival let it be a thing that is
because of the thing I feel like those
dudes were just doing that yeah it's an
excuse to do it that's not a common
thing I've ever seen it usually like Gio
saying just women dancing in their
costumes having a great time like I
thought he was gonna be mad at that and
he was like oh that's not cool we should
stop that that's people probably
shouldn't do that in public whatever but
that's like getting mad at like a drunk
person to Mario golf or throwing up on
his friends yeah like that's it to me
that's all part of the same custom it's
like this this beautiful custom that we
all so that one girl that's like that
over another person that's just holding
their hairs little he bent over and he
was perfectly balanced you know what I
mean well some people that's true
bending over you already get dizzy no
you're done didn't you or you start
throwing up he could he could have been
pre throw up right there
you don't know throw up throw up it's
not your water right now drawn people I
just have a problem with anyone
criticizing drunk people I just don't
like it I think that drunk I think that
drunk people are my people until I don't
like it I don't like it
it's punching down its punching down I
like watching drunk people at a distance
to see see them fail at life oh but I
went there to close
no not definitely not close so now the
workers party has said that they would
be taking the president to court for
sharing pornography oh you two strike on
his channel
man he's like I'm the president / zoom
ahead man the butt was out you can't
the peanuts without you could see the
penis it's crazy that is Wow that's it
that's the thing we didn't even think
about because of our president now like
the president tweeted out that viral
video Brazil generally you'd be like a
fan you're the president like retweet
only kicked we didn't straight from your
can get away from your Twitter I think
yeah I like I just needs a PR team
probably has some vendetta against
Carnival already yeah he was just
waiting for his moment where he could be
like see this is what I've been talking
to me his ex-girlfriend started it she
broke up with his best girlfriend worked
away from him during carnival for her
and she just kept working disappeared in
the sea full of people is really an
origin story like why do you hate
carnival she worked away from me yeah
and that's what I know I had to destroy
this he became a president just so he
could destroy carnival take it up man I
miss Brazilian barbecue
he's like a diabolical villain I just
had Brazilian barbecue last week where
did you go
Fogerty child okay so good yeah I
actually want to be stinking rose first
and I was very disappointed it's so over
prices ìholy yeah and not good the deck
horse cool the chorus super dope it was
the best part about it and then we
literally walked out and around the
corner in the foliated child and had the
time of our life yeah just beef oh yeah
I loved it
what is it yes yes yeah it's so cool
they're just like you want to look like
sure what is it Mon card and the off
card yeah
I love cheese bread you at the very end
that pineapple with the cinnamon that's
the best I actually want to go to
carnival now meet you
I want to go cuz of now but I reminded
me like always shoot that's one country
that I haven't really I really wanted to
go but I never got a chance to be scared
to visit the country because it sounds
like it's really really it's not like
you're gonna go straight into the
favelas for sure but they're saying like
even in a regular tourist area from what
I've heard I don't know it sounds scary
just like in Mexico it sounds [ __ ]
scary like to go to Cancun there's
tourists that are getting killed that's
pretty crazy - well maybe um what I
heard Rio is more dangerous but there's
the other one so bow Saul Powell yeah it
could probably be crazy at the airport
already when we were landing and we went
to Tulum we landed in the Cancun Airport
and the minute you land at a Mexican
Airport you're like they're [ __ ]
there's just no organization it was just
a big-ass mob of people and then I had
like the biggest respect for TSA cuz I
like even though these guys suck they
still keep some sort of order mmm when
you land in a Mexican Airport you're
like oh [ __ ] this is zero artists is it
feel like the border like how crazy it
is out there it feels like Black Friday
like you didn't know they were like
everyone was just bunched up like in
hopes that they were standing where
there might be a line it was really bad
I asked the lady in a uniform
oh is this is this for like the native
Mexican passports and this is for like
foreign passports she's like they're all
lying there are lines all right thank
you
oh they mainly get foreigners there like
there's just like that one tiny little I
got my Spanish and she was like no
they're all lines I'm like what are you
taught there is no law are you stupid
Oh open your mind I think that's the
thing about traveling and then you're in
their world now and even though you have
higher standards of organization and
other things you just kind of blend or
else you're gonna die you're gonna die
from frustration like you're gonna go
there
and you're like dude just so much
smarter to like form a line and then
tell people this is the line for this
and is and they don't want to do it but
I'm like alright [ __ ] it if I if I'm
gonna Drive myself crazy
you just start [ __ ] moving I just
like blank that out and I'll like I'll
get there when I get there and I just
start talking to friends yeah we just
joined the mob yeah and somehow this
whole giant like mob like rave amoeba
theme just move and if you have to bribe
the officer you bribe the officer and
it's like [ __ ] um you know dude
that's like what up dude when I got to
Bali for the first time I arrived many
hours before Nicky like eight hours
before Nicky because we're on separate
flights from different places so I was
there I was in Singapore to teach young
Singaporean filmmakers about
screenwriter that sound like a troll it
does sound like good trust I'll never
know when he's telling the truth or not
really so yeah I was there for that and
I was part of this program that maker
studios put together or whatever
whatever whatever who cares okay so uh
so then Nicky's like we should go to
Bali because it's like really close to
two hours from here on a plane yeah and
so I told maker I was like hey we're
gonna go to Bali so booked my flight
home from Bali
so they booked my flight differently
than Nicky's does that make sense yeah
okay so when I got there it's organized
chaos like when you land you're you're
there and then you walk out to get a
like a taxi and it's like you get mobbed
by so many people like it's great you
because you're white no no everyone as
they come out sequentially everyone's
get mom he's got money yeah look he's
the king no but um so yeah so then I was
like man Nikki's gonna have to come deal
with this eight hours from now I'm just
gonna stay here so I waited in the
airport for eight hours dude why are you
just like the attention everyone calling
you King yeah
I just stood in the middle of them he
goes no I don't need a taxi ride I'm
gonna do no I don't need a taxi brother
Luther just stood there while he got
sunburned yeah it's an indoor airport
okay it's actually partially outdoors is
it Marshall tan are there hustling taxi
rides all day long the whole day like
please sir would you like a cab ride
then even when you're when you walk up
into the food court area the whole time
to like taxi taxi and you're like no
dad's no taxi no - yeah you should just
have a sign I know I know but they would
just see the taxi part back taxi gave a
no taxi I'm like what is your word for
know I should have printed that
[Music]